Prof: Good morning
everybody.
This is the last lecture in
Roman Architecture,
and I think it's appropriate
that I deliver this last
lecture,
which I call "Rome of
Constantine and a New
Rome," on Rome's birthday.
Indeed, this is Rome's birthday
today, April 21^(st),
2009.
Rome was born,
as you'll recall,
on the 21^(st) of April in 753
B.C., which means that Rome is
2762 years old today.
And since birthdays are often
celebrated with cake and ice
cream,
I should make good today on the
promise that I made to you at
the very beginning of the
semester,
which is that sometime in the
course of this semester I would
recommend four ice cream places
to you,
four gelaterias in Rome, to you.
And I've only recommended two.
I recommended Tre Scalini in
Piazza Navona,
and I recommended the Della
Palma that is located near the
Pantheon.
So I haven't--there are two
more to go.
And it seemed on Rome's
birthday, this was the perfect
thing to begin the lecture with,
and that is to round the circle
and make you aware of the two
other best ice cream places in
Rome.
And I show you here,
on the left-hand side of the
screen, Giolitti,
and on the right-hand side of
the screen San Crispino.
And note the birthday balloons,
and that I'm enjoying myself
very much on Rome's birthday,
today.
But just so that you know where
these are.
You know Rome so well by now
that I think I can give you
directions that are going to
make sense to you.
So you are in the core of
ancient Rome.
You've just been to visit the
Colosseum and the Roman Forum.
Maybe you've been up on the
Capitoline Hill.
You're exploring the Victor
Emmanuel Monument,
and so with your back to the
Victor Emmanuel Monument,
look straight ahead and you see
the Corso,
the so-called Corso,
the street of the racecourses,
or the racecourse,
where the popes,
by the way, used to race their
horses.
You stand facing the Corso.
You walk down the Corso.
You're on your way,
in this regard,
toward the Piazza di Spagna,
the Spanish Steps.
But before you get to the
Spanish Steps,
you're going to notice one,
the only department store in
Rome,
Rinascente--that's why it's a
good landmark--
Rinascente, on the right.
You take a left and you're
going to see the Column of
Marcus Aurelius,
which is a column we didn't
look at this semester,
but is based on the Column of
Trajan.
You take a look at the Column
of Marcus Aurelius.
You continue into the next
piazza, which is the Piazza
Montecitorio,
with a great obelisk in the
center and a government building
and a couple of hotels.
You stay on the right and you
go down that next small street
and you hit Giolitti,
which in my opinion is the
single best ice cream place in
Rome.
So if you're in Rome,
not to be missed.
It has the best fruit flavors
in the city of Rome;
in fact, anywhere in Italy that
I know of.
And the second one that I
mention to you is San Crispino.
San Crispino is near the Trevi
Fountain in Rome.
So you're going to go to the
Trevi Fountain in any case,
and all you need to do when
you're facing the Trevi Fountain
is to go about two blocks away
from the Trevi Fountain and you
will hit San Crispino.
It has a smaller selection of
flavors, but everything is very,
very good there.
In fact, they've been such a
success that they have expanded
and opened another one near the
Pantheon.
So again, back to the Pantheon,
down that small street--I
already gave you the directions
to Della Palma.
You go beyond Della Palma,
you take a left and you'll hit
the second San Crispino.
So very important to share this
with you, again before the term
is up, and in honor of Rome's
birthday.
Also, of course,
when you're at San Crispino,
don't forget the Trevi
Fountain.
And you probably all know the
tradition that when you go and
visit the Trevi Fountain,
which is always very
crowded--this is actually a
small crowd compared to what's
usually there--
after you've looked at it,
and enjoyed it for its own sake
and for architecture,
obviously, of a much later
period but I think one you can
see is very closely based on a
lot of things that we've been
looking at this semester.
After you've looked at it--and
people usually do this right
before they leave Rome;
you go up to the fountain,
bring a coin--
it can be an American coin or
an Italian coin or any coin for
that matter--
you stand in front of the Trevi
Fountain,
with your back to the Trevi
you take a coin,
you throw it over your
shoulder--
got to make sure it goes into
the water and not on the side--
but throw it into the water,
and that will ensure that you
will get to return to Rome
someday.
So don't forget to do that as
well.
We spoke in the last lecture
about the Tetrarchy,
about Diocletian and his
formation of the Tetrarchy,
and his attempt to bring
stability back to Rome and to
the Empire,
and how successful he was
indeed.
We also talked about the fact
that Diocletian and the other
Tetrarchs were responsible for
some important building
projects,
in fact, bringing architecture
back to Rome in a way that it
had been missing in the third
century A.D.
And I mentioned in particular
that Diocletian was interested
both in public and in private
architecture.
And I remind you of an example
of public architecture that we
looked at last time,
on the top left,
the so-called Five Column
Monument,
or Decennial Monument,
or Tetrachic Monument,
that Diocletian erected in the
Roman Forum to honor himself and
to honor his formation of the
Tetrarchy,
and his relationship to Jupiter.
You'll remember the five
columns: four with the Tetrarchs
imaged on the top in the front,
the one of Jupiter behind,
that this was located behind
the Rostra or the speaker's
platform in the Roman Forum.
We also talked about the fact
that Diocletian was interested
again in private architecture,
that he built a palace for
himself,
a place that he hoped to retire
to,
on the Dalmatian Coast where he
was born,
at a place called Split.
And I remind you of it here,
a restored view showing you
what it looked like;
that it was essentially a
fortified camp,
designed like a Roman
castrum,
with walls and towers and a
very distinctive octagonal
mausoleum that was located
across from the Temple of
Jupiter.
So again his connecting himself
to Jupiter, honoring Jupiter as
he honors himself.
And I also showed you an
example of the portraiture of
the Tetrarchs.
We talked about the
all-for-one-and-one-for-all
philosophy,
how they stuck together,
not only in life but in their
portraits,
and they depicted themselves,
or they had themselves depicted
as this foursome,
in large part again to
underscore the fact that all
four of them were co-equal
emperors,
that all four of them--or
almost co-equal emperors:
you'll remember that there were
Augusti and Caesars,
so some had the slight upper
hand, but for the most part they
worked together.
They're represented as a whole,
and they're represented in a
very similar way to one another.
And we talked about the use of
geometric forms,
the abstraction,
the solidity of these portraits
that I suggested mirrors this
new stability that Diocletian
and the Tetrarchy have brought
to Rome and to the Empire.
And we saw that those same
qualities, that interest in
geometry, in abstraction,
in solidity,
were characteristic also of
Tetrarchic architecture.
And we're going to see some of
those features continuing on in
the buildings that we're going
to be looking at today.
Diocletian stepped down,
retired voluntarily,
on the first of May in 305 A.D.
And Maximian,
his co-Augustus,
stepped down as well,
and the two Caesars were
elevated to Augusti,
and two new Caesars were
chosen.
But without the strong presence
of Diocletian the Tetrarchy fell
apart, and Rome and the Empire
were once again plunged into
civil war.
The two main claimants for
imperial power that came out of
this civil war were Maxentius--
Maxentius who was the son of
Maximian--
and Constantine--Constantine
who eventually became
Constantine the Great--
Constantine who was the son of
Constantius Chlorus.
And these two men,
Constantine and Maxentius,
warred with one another for
imperial power,
and they went against one
another in one of the most
famous battles of all time:
in fact,
a battle that is as well known,
if not even more well known,
than the Battle of Actium,
and this is the Battle of the
Milvian Bridge,
the Battle of the Milvian
Bridge which took place in 312
A.D.
And it was at that epic-making
battle that Constantine was
victorious over Maxentius,
that Constantine became sole
emperor of Rome --
so a move away from the
Tetrarchy and the placement of
power in the hands of one man.
Once again, Constantine becomes
sole emperor of Rome.
And it was at that same battle,
the Battle of the Milvian
Bridge--
and one of the reasons that
it's such an important battle in
historical terms is the fact
that it was at that Battle of
the Milvian Bridge that
Constantine was said to have
seen the vision of the cross;
the vision of the cross that
helped him to be victorious,
eventually led him to convert to
Christianity,
which he did on his deathbed.
He was baptized a Christian on
his deathbed.
One of the most interesting
things that we'll talk about
today,
and about the architecture
under Constantine the Great,
is that we will see,
because he began as a pagan
emperor and ended his life as a
Christian emperor,
he has in a sense one foot in
the pagan past and the other
foot in the Christian future,
and we're going to see that
reflected in the architecture
that he commissioned,
as we look at that today.
A few coins of Constantine
which I think will help set the
stage for this one foot in the
past and one foot in the future,
that is going to be the
leitmotif of today's lecture.
I show you on the left-hand
side of the screen a coin of
Constantine, when he first began
his rise to power.
It was probably struck in
around 306 A.D.
And it's an interesting coin,
because if you remember--
I didn't bring it back to show
you--
but if you remember the coin of
Diocletian that I showed you,
you'll recall that he was
represented in a very similar
fashion.
It's the sort of bearded
blockhead style,
as I call it,
for the Tetrarchy;
a very cubic image,
a short, military hairstyle,
closely cropped,
and a short beard that adheres
very closely to the shape of the
face,
and the face masked itself with
cubic geometric forms.
So we see Constantine in his
very early portrait trying to
look like a Tetrarch,
trying to look like his father,
Constantius Chlorus,
trying to look like Diocletian,
trying to fit in,
before he figures out the way
that's going to enable him,
in fact, to become emperor,
sole emperor of Rome.
After he defeats Maxentius,
at the Battle of the Milvian
Bridge,
we see the greatest
transformation in the history of
Roman portraiture,
in the history of self-imaging
by emperors,
by people in power,
and that is this transformation
that I can show you from this
early coin of 306,
to a coin that dates after the
Battle of the Milvian Bridge,
and that also represents
Constantine.
And what you see has happened
here is Constantine has shaved
off his beard,
he has lost about twenty years
of age,
and he is shown with an
entirely different hairstyle.
Not the short military
hairstyle that he wore because
he wanted to liken himself to
his father and to Diocletian,
but an entirely new hairstyle,
but one--
for any of you who know your
Roman portraiture or remember
the portraits that I showed you
fleetingly of Augustus and the
Julio-Claudians--
he is wearing a cap of hair
that is very similar to--
a fuller cap of hair,
with comma-shaped locks over
his forehead,
growing long on the nape of his
neck,
that is characteristic of
Augustus and also of Trajan.
He's in fact a neo-Augustus in
this image, with a neo-Trajanic
hairstyle.
Why?
Because he is--as sole emperor
he has made the decision that he
wants to now ally himself,
not with the Tetrarchs,
which are of the past at this
point,
but rather with the great
emperors of the past:
with Augustus,
with Trajan,
and as we'll see also with
Hadrian and with Marcus
Aurelius.
And we can see that very
important break here,
and we'll see it also in
architecture.
Another coin down here
representing Constantine,
with a bunch of pagan regalia.
We see him, as so many of the
earlier emperors of Rome,
depicted along with a patron
god, in this case the god
Helios, the god of the sun.
And you can see Constantine in
the foreground,
Helios in the background:
Helios represented with a rayed
crown--
and that's why we know it's
him--silhouetted right behind
the emperor.
The emperor is shown as
warlike, with military costume,
a spear, and then a shield over
here.
And if we look closely at the
shield we'll see the depiction
of someone in a chariot,
led by four horses,
coming--it's represented
frontally;
it's the solar chariot,
the solar chariot of Helios.
So a coin that is very much in
the usual pagan tradition,
where we see Constantine
associating himself with the
pagan past and with a pagan god,
in this case Helios.
This coin, however,
that was also made after the
Battle of the Milvian Bridge,
shows us a very different
Constantine.
It's an interesting frontal
portrait, which is rare on Roman
coins.
He is still shown as the
warrior.
He's in military costume.
He's holding the reins of his
horse, who's also depicted
nicely in this portrait on this
coin.
If you look very closely at his
shield,
you will actually see that it
still is decorated with a pagan
symbol,
with the she-wolf suckling
Romulus and Remus.
But look up here.
The scepter that he carries is
not the usual scepter or spear
that we see in pagan imagery,
but a cross scepter,
a cross scepter and--
I don't know if you can see it
from where you sit--
he wears a medallion on the top
of his very elaborate helmet,
with plumage and so on,
a medallion that has the
Chi-Rho,
C-h-i, dash,
R-h-o, the Chi-Rho,
which was the Christian
monogram.
So we see him in this image,
not as the great pagan warrior,
but as the new Christian
crusader.
So a very important change from
paganism to Christianity,
that as I mentioned already we
will see also reflected in
Constantine's architecture.
Constantine learned a lot
though from the Tetrarchs,
and one of the things that he
continued on was to build great
public architecture;
public architecture for the
benefit of the Roman populace at
large.
He follows the lead of
Diocletian in this regard and
adds another very large imperial
bath to Rome;
and I show you a plan of that
imperial bath here.
It bears his name,
the Baths of Constantine,
and dates to 320 A.D.
It is located in Rome.
It is located on the Quirinal
Hill, the Quirinal Hill.
And that should ring a bell for
all of you,
because you'll remember it was
Trajan--
Trajan, and remember
Constantine is imaging himself
as a neo-Augustus with a
neo-Trajanic hairstyle--
Trajan who built--who had much,
a good part of the Quirinal
Hill cut back to make way for
his forum,
and then placed his markets on
part of what remained of the
Quirinal Hill.
So the Quirinal Hill was
associated in everybody's mind
with Trajan.
Constantine wanted to associate
himself with Trajan.
So when he decides where to
place his new bath structure,
he chooses the Quirinal Hill.
This is not coincidental;
it was very deliberative on his
part.
He builds it in a manner that
is completely consistent with
imperial bath architecture in
Rome: the imperial bath type of
architecture in Rome that we've
already studied,
from the time of Titus,
up through the time of
Diocletian.
The baths on the Quirinal Hill
are no longer preserved,
but we fortunately have some
drawings that were made by the
famous architect Andrea
Palladio,
P-a-l-l-a-d-i-o,
Andrea Palladio,
who drew it when it was in
better shape,
and his drawings of the Baths
of Constantine allow us to see
exactly what these baths were
like in their heyday.
And we can see,
although Palladio's drawing
concentrates on the bathing
block,
you can see that he also
includes down here--
and it's probably that this is
all that remained of this
particular part of the bath in
Palladio's time--
you can see he includes down
here the great hemicycle that
we've seen in so many of these
baths,
that are part of that precinct
that surrounds the bath block.
So this suggests to us,
and I think very convincingly,
that this bath,
this bathing block,
was also placed in one of these
very large precincts that had
all the seminar and lecture
rooms and libraries around the
perimeter of it,
and that this was lined with
seats and probably used for
people to watch athletic
contests,
or perhaps even plays of other
kinds.
The bathing block again we can
see conforms extremely well to
the other baths that we've
looked at,
to the Baths of Caracalla and
Diocletian,
for example,
with a natatio,
rectangular in shape,
with a frigidarium that
is also rectangular and has
three--
a triple groin vault,
as you can see designated in
Palladio's drawing,
and down here--this is a
re-interpretation,
by the way, of Palladio's
drawing from Ward-Perkins,
this plan that you see on the
screen now.
A tepidarium over here
that's somewhat more unusual in
shape than we tend to see,
where we have a series of
lobes, four lobes in fact,
that have been--that have
expanded the space almost--
well it's sort of a circle,
trying to become an oval,
I suppose--but you can see the
way in which they have expanded,
and we call that kind of space
quadrilobate,
and we see that here.
And then we also see--this is
most interesting -- how the
caldarium is treated.
Because as you've seen in the
baths that we've looked at,
the imperial baths that we've
looked at,
if there's any room that's
different in each of these it's
the caldarium.
You'll recall that Diocletian
had moved to a rectangular
caldarium,
with radiating alcoves.
But Constantine and his
architects move back to the
circular caldarium that
we saw in the Baths of
Caracalla,
uses the same sort of scheme
here, with three radiating
alcoves,
all of those screened from the
outer space with columns,
and the rest of the structure,
around these main rooms of the
bathing block that are related
to one another,
axially we see the other rooms
symmetrically disposed.
One other important point to
make about the caldarium
is that we see that it too
corresponds to a development
that we've already begun to see
in some of the other buildings
that we looked at,
especially in the last lecture,
and that is this move away from
the oculus for
round-domed buildings.
This round--this
caldarium does not have
an oculus,
as so many caldaria did
in the past;
think back to the--well or so
many bathing rooms did--think
back to the frigidaria in
Pompeii, for example,
with their oculus.
The oculus is no longer
used here,
and instead we see windows in
the base of the dome that are
very similar to the windows that
we saw in a couple of Tetrarchic
buildings.
We're going to see it elsewhere
today, and I'll reiterate that
point then.
Constantine,
like so many Roman emperors
before him,
did complete buildings that had
been begun by his predecessors,
and he did this for some of the
Tetrarchs,
including his father,
not surprisingly,
Constantius Chlorus.
We know that Constantius
Chlorus had chosen as his
capital the city of Trier,
the city of Trier,
in what was Gaul but now is
Germany.
And I show you the location of
Trier.
This is a map showing the
locations,
as we've discussed so many
times this term,
of many of the--of all of the
places that we've looked at in
the Western Empire.
And you can see the French
cities that we looked at just
last time,
in Gaul, and then up there
Trier, in what is now Germany,
located near the modern city of
Cologne.
This was the chosen capital for
Constantius Chlorus.
Even before Constantius Chlorus
began to build a palace for
himself at Trier,
as the other Tetrarchs had done
elsewhere in the Roman
provinces,
there was quite a bit of
building activity going on with
regard to one project in Trier,
in the third century,
and not surprisingly that too
was a defensive wall.
That part of the Empire was
being attacked on a regular
basis by Germanic tribes,
by the Franks and by the
Alemanni, were coming in,
wreaking havoc in that part of
the world,
and a decision was taken,
not surprisingly,
in 275 and 276--because you'll
remember that's exactly when the
Aurelian Walls were dedicated in
Rome,
275--to build a major wall in
this part of the Empire as well.
And we have some part of that
wall still preserved,
especially a gate in that wall
called the Porta Nigra,
which I show you here on the
right-hand side of the screen.
The Porta Nigra which,
although the walls were begun
in the 270s--
so the walls date primarily in
the third century--
this particular gate was not
added to the walls until the
early fourth century A.D.,
during the time of Constantius
Chlorus,
and Constantine completes this
gateway and those baths .
If we compare the gate at the
Porta Nigra in Trier to the gate
that we looked at from the
Aurelian Walls,
the so-called Porta Appia that
does date to around 275--
and you see it again in this
restored view from Ward-Perkins,
on the left-hand side of the
screen--
you will see the close
resemblance of the Porta Nigra
to the Porta Maggiore in Rome.
By that I mean both of them
have two arcuated entranceways;
both of them have round towers,
as you can see here;
both of them have arcuated
windows or blind windows,
as you can see;
in the case of the Porta Nigra
they have columns between them,
which is not the case in the
Porta Appia.
The main difference between
these two is that the Porta
Appia in Rome you'll recall was
made out of concrete faced with
brick,
the most contemporary building
material,
whereas you can clearly see by
looking at the Porta Nigra that
the Porta Nigra is made out of
stone,
out of cut stone construction
-- extremely old-fashioned at
this particular time.
But I think it is very likely
that they wanted,
by choosing this for this
particular part of the world--
and it is--this cut stone
construction is local stone--
by choosing this,
they wanted to reassert a
relationship between the early
fourth century A.D.
and earlier Rome,
and especially earlier Rome and
imperial power,
the very symbols of Roman
power, buildings like the
Theater of Marcellus,
and especially the Colosseum in
Rome;
we've talked about that as the
very icon of Rome,
its ability to impress and to
awe.
And I think they wanted to take
advantage of that kind of awe
inspiring rhetoric,
you know, visual rhetoric that
such a choice could make.
And I think it's an example of
the fact,
just as Constantine reaches
back to emperors like Trajan and
Augustus,
to associate himself with in
his portraiture,
I think that they had reason to
look back to some of the great
buildings of the Roman past,
and to use that kind of visual
imagery to reassert that Rome,
despite the fact that they were
being attacked by barbarians,
all was well in Rome,
or continued to be well in the
capital,
as well as on the frontiers,
and this kind of image I think
worked in that regard.
Well one hopes that--well they
thought it would work at any
rate in that regard,
even into the early fourth
century A.D.
Here's another view,
the same view,
of the Porta Nigra.
And I compare it also to a
detail from the Porta Maggiore
in Rome, which you'll recall was
built by Claudius.
There is an interesting
resemblance between the two,
and many scholars have called
attention to that,
because the stone of the Porta
Nigra is not as smoothed over as
the stone of the Colosseum or
the Theater of Marcellus;
it's left in a much more rough
state, a rough state that
reminds one of the rusticated
masonry of Claudius' Porta
Maggiore.
But remember that in the case
of the Porta Maggiore,
there was a deliberate
disjunction between the
rusticated masonry and the
finished masonry;
the finished capitals and also
the finished pediments above.
And we talked about the fact
that we believe that that has a
lot to do with the particular
personality and antiquarian
interests of Claudius,
who liked the intellectual
exercise and idea of playing off
one against the other.
We don't see that same
combination here.
We don't see the rough and the
finished, in the case of the
Porta Nigra in Trier.
And it has been suggested,
and I think correctly so,
that the reason that the Porta
Nigra looks the way it does is
not deliberate,
the way the Porta Maggiore is,
but rather because it really
was unfinished;
the blocks were never fully
smoothed over.
But it makes a very attractive
appearance even still today,
despite that.
So Constantine completed this
gateway, but he also completed
the palace that had been begun
by his father;
Constantius Chlorus had begun a
palace in Trier.
The palace had a very large and
impressive bath building,
as a piece of it,
and it also had this building
that is usually referred to
today as the Aula Palatina or
the Basilica --
the Aula Palatina or the
Basilica.
We're not exactly sure how it
was used in the palace,
but possibly in the same way
that the basilica was in the
Palace of Domitian on the
Palatine Hill,
as a place where he could sit
and try cases himself.
It may have been used in the
same fashion here.
And I can show you it's
extremely well preserved.
It dates to 300 to 310 A.D.;
again, part of the Palace of
Constantius Chlorus,
completed by Constantine.
We see a plan and a restored
view from Ward-Perkins now on
the screen.
And if you look at the plan,
you will see that in the main
it follows the basilican plan
that we've become so accustomed
to: a great open rectangular
space with an apse on one end,
and with all attention drawn
toward that apse.
So in that sense again,
one foot in the pagan past;
it looks back to basilicas of
an earlier date,
be they the one in Domitian's
Palace or the Forum of Trajan in
Rome.
But there are some differences
here.
One of them is the fact that
you can see that there are no
columns inside the cella.
That's interesting,
and it is in keeping with the
Tetrarchic aesthetic that we've
already described,
for the Curia,
for example,
with a box-like open space
inside,
without any columnar decoration
at all.
No columns in here;
stark, geometric,
abstract in the Tetrachic
manner.
But they have placed columns on
the outside of the Basilica,
in a kind of courtyard on
either side,
columns that you can see here,
which is a very interesting and
unusual and in fact unique
approach.
You can also see there is a
transverse corridor over here,
and that--a transverse--a
vestibule,
a transverse vestibule,
entrance vestibule,
which is unusual and which we
don't see in typical Roman
basilican architecture.
We call that a narthex,
n-a-r-t-h-e-x,
and this addition of the
narthex here,
the transverse vestibule,
is interesting because it is
going to become the basis for
most church architecture,
both from the time--basilican
church architecture--
in the time of Constantine,
because Constantine does found
Old--
does build Old St.
Peter's and other churches in
Rome, and others follow suit.
So again, one foot in the pagan
past, one in the Christian
future.
On the left-hand side of the
screen,
the restored view of the
exterior, shows not only those
low-lying columnar courtyards,
but also that there were
railings on two stories.
It does show you as well--and
the building is made out of
solid brick--
it does show you as well the
rounded windows,
the arched windows,
which we have seen.
The round topped windows which
we have seen have become
customary for Tetrarchic
architecture,
as well as the very interesting
use of projecting elements,
that are very simple -- they
look almost like pilasters,
but they're not pilasters,
they're a simplified,
abstract version of pilasters.
So this paring down of the
elements that is so consistent
with the Tetrarchic ethos.
Here's a view of the Aula
Palatina as it looks today.
Again, it is extremely well
preserved, as you can see,
but it no longer has its outer
courtyard and it no longer has
its railings.
But the rest is there.
You can see these wonderful
round-headed windows and how
large they are.
We've talked about the ability
of architects to dematerialize
the wall at this point in time,
and the way in which they have
opened it up with very large
windows.
And you can see what I was
describing just before,
these molded elements that
project out into our space.
They kind of look like they're
made to conjure up pilasters,
but they don't have any
capitals and they don't have any
bases;
they're, in my mind,
a kind of abstract version of a
pilaster.
And they're very effective,
I think, in terms of the
aesthetic appeal of this
particular building.
While the Basilica at the
Palace at Trier,
the Palace of Constantius
Chlorus at Trier,
is so clearly based on earlier
Roman basilican architecture,
it looks to the future.
And if we look around Rome in
the years following the
construction of buildings like
the Aula Palatina,
we see lots of early churches.
I show you the church of Santa
Sabina, S-a-b-i-n-a,
Santa Sabina in Rome,
which dates to 425 A.D.,
so the fifth century A.D.
And I think you can see how
similar it is to the Aula
Palatina: the basilican form;
the apse at the end;
the very large round-topped
windows that we see in the
Basilica at Trier.
The interior of the Aula
Palatina is also very well
preserved.
You see a view of it here.
It has been transformed,
not surprisingly,
into a church in later times.
It's a perfect space for that.
And I think it's well worth
comparing it to the interior of
the Curia that we looked at last
time,
because again it shows a vision
of the Tetrarchy --
a vision that is consistent
from Rome to the provinces;
this whole idea of paring
things down to their basics,
of creating a box-like shape,
no columnar architecture
whatsoever,
a very sparsely decorated
rectangular space with a flat
ceiling and with round-headed
windows.
We see the same concept here.
Here they've placed the
round-headed windows on two
stories, which has opened the
building up even more and
allowed light to flow into it;
no columnar decoration
whatsoever.
The scheme of two rows of
round-headed windows,
in the niche as well,
also opening it up,
dematerializing it,
allowing light to stream into
the building in what is a very
spiritual way,
and again not at all surprising
that it would be transformed in
later times into a church.
Once again one foot in the
pagan past, one in the Christian
future.
I show you a restored
view--we've looked at it
before--of the Basilica Ulpia in
Rome, part of the Forum of
Trajan.
It's that kind of thing,
that kind of basilican plan
that lies behind the design of
the Basilica at the Palace of
Constantius Chlorus in Trier.
But it also looks forward to
others.
I show you here the interior of
Santa Sabina.
This might not have been the
best to choose,
because you can see the columns
have been reintroduced in the
interior of Santa Sabina.
But if you think those columns
away and just look at the way in
which the apse is designed,
with the round-headed windows,
the same round-headed windows
in the upper story up here,
I think that you can see how
much it owes to buildings like
the Aula Palatina.
The round dome building type,
just like the basilican type,
was to be very important in the
Constantinian period,
and also in later times.
And I show you--I remind you of
some of the important domed
rooms that we've looked at in
the course of this semester:
at the frigidarium at
the Stabian Baths of Pompeii;
at the Temple of Mercury from
the spa at Baia,
the so-called Temple of
Mercury;
the octagonal room of Nero's
Domus Aurea;
and the dome of the Pantheon
here on the far right.
There is no more important form
in Roman architecture than the
domed room,
very characteristic of the
Romans, and a special gift that
they passed on to posterity,
as you well know.
And this type of building
continued to be explored in the
Constantinian period.
I could show you several
examples, but I've chosen to
show you just one of those;
and it's the one that you now
see on the screen in plan,
a plan from Ward-Perkins.
This is the so-called
"Temple of Minerva
Medica" in Rome.
It's not a temple at all.
It dates to the early fourth
century A.D.
It's not a temple,
but what it was,
was a pavilion in a garden.
We know that an emperor of the
third century A.D.
by the name of Gallienus,
G-a-l-l-i-e-n-u-s,
Gallienus, was responsible for
building some imperial gardens
in the third century A.D.
-- so this was another project
that did happen in the third
century A.D.,
the building of some imperial
gardens for the enjoyment of the
emperors and of the imperial
family.
And it was in these gardens
that were created in the third
century that this pavilion was
added,
during the Constantinian
period, in the early fourth
century A.D.
And I show you a plan of that
temple,
that so-called Temple of
Minerva Medica,
or this pavilion in the
so-called Licinian,
L-i-c-i-n-i-a-n,
the Licinian Gardens,
as commissioned by Gallienus,
the Licinian Gardens.
And we see it here.
And it's very interesting
because although it clearly--
it's a building made out of
concrete,
faced with brick--and although
it clearly is based on some of
the buildings that I just showed
you--
the typical round structure
with oculus,
the frigidaria,
the spa, the octagonal room,
and the Pantheon--you can see
that the architects of this
period were still able to
innovate,
and have gone further by
creating not a round building,
although at first it looks
round, or an octagonal building,
but a decagonal building,
a ten-sided building.
And you can see ten--you can
see radiating apses,
nine, and then the entranceway
over here.
So ten-sided structure.
If you look very carefully at
the plan you will notice though
that the uppermost apse,
the one that is located
directly across from the
entranceway,
is a tiny bit larger than the
others.
So that gives the building a
little bit--
even though it's a round
building--a little bit of a
longitudinal axis,
which is very interesting --
this incorporation of a
longitudinal axis into a round
structure.
You can also see the way in
which the radiating apses,
the two on either side,
left and right,
are screened by columns,
in a way that we've also become
accustomed to.
And I believe that those
columns, yes I'm pretty sure,
that those columns have a
triple arcuation up above.
So that--yes,
you can see that in plan--
a triple arcuation above that
we've seen also is
characteristic of late Roman
architecture,
not only in the private sphere,
as this is,
but also in the more public
sphere.
But going back to that
longitudinal axis,
look also at the entrance
vestibule.
This is another one of these
narthexes,
this cross--this transverse
vestibule,
in this case with apses on
either end,
that is characteristic of these
early fourth-century A.D.
Roman, pagan Roman buildings,
but is going to become a
hallmark of Christian
architecture,
not only basilican
that is churches in the form of
basilicas,
but small religious structures
that are circular in general
plan.
So a very interesting plan in
that regard, and a very
innovative plan in the early
fourth century A.D.
The building is still preserved.
I can show it to you.
I can show you the outside,
as well as some details of the
inside of the building,
as you see here.
It was made out of concrete,
faced with brick,
as I mentioned before.
We are looking at the interior,
up toward the dome.
You can see something very
interesting here,
which is the addition of
ribbed--of bricks to create ribs
in the dome,
to give it something of a sense
of a segmented dome,
which is a building technique
that we see sometimes in late
Roman architecture.
And you can also see--although
it looks like it has an
oculus,
that's just because most of the
roof has fallen in;
it did not have an
oculus.
Instead the lighting was
provided through these
round-headed windows that we
see, very large round-headed
windows at the base of the dome.
So again this move away,
in late antiquity,
from the oculus to using
these very large round-headed
windows to light the interior of
the building.
And this is a view of the
so-called Temple of Minerva
Medica as it looks today,
from the outside,
where you can see those same
round-headed buildings ,
sort of piers,
that are not so different from
the ones that we saw at Trier,
used rather than columns to
decorate the structure.
A large round-headed doorway
down here.
You can see the scale--this is
a pretty big pavilion in a
garden--you can see its scale in
relationship to the cars that
surround it.
So continued innovation in
round architecture under
Constantine the Great,
and a building type that is
going to have a long history in
the Medieval period,
in the Byzantine period,
and well beyond.
I show you just one example of
the impact that it had on later
church architecture.
This is the Church of San
Vitale, a very famous church in
Ravenna, in Italy,
that honors Justinian,
the famous Justinian,
and Theodora.
It was built in the sixth
century A.D.
And I think you can see by
looking at a view of the
exterior plan,
and also a view of the
interior, how important
architectural experiments under
the Romans were for buildings
like this: the massing of the
outside;
the geometry,
the interest in geometry;
simple forms;
round-headed windows.
So similar to the aesthetic
that we saw in the Curia or in
the Basilica at Trier.
The plan above,
in this case an octagon with a
central area,
with radiating alcoves;
very similar to the sorts of
things that we see,
not just in the Domus Aurea,
but also in the Temple of
Minerva Medica.
And you can see the narthex
here, just as we saw it in the
Temple of Minerva Medica.
And you can see in this view of
the interior,
for example,
the triple arches on top of the
two columns --
all of these motifs taken over
clearly from Roman architecture,
ancient Roman architecture,
and exploited in the Medieval
and Byzantine periods.
The single most important
building that I am going to show
you today is the one that I want
to turn to now.
And this is the so-called
Basilica Nova,
or the Basilica of
Maxentius-Constantine.
I can't over-emphasize the
significance of this incredible
building.
It is a building that
demonstrates to us that
Constantine not only completed
commissions that had been begun
by his father,
such as the palace at Trier and
the Porta Nigra,
but also by other Tetrarchs,
and in this case by his rival,
Maxentius.
We know that this building was
begun by Maxentius,
which is why it is sometimes
referred to as the Basilica of
Maxentius-Constantine,
or more easily the Basilica
Nova.
It was begun by Maxentius in
306 A.D.
When Constantine was victorious
over Maxentius at the Battle of
the Milvian Bridge,
he took it over and he
completed it in his own name:
so hence the Basilica of
Maxentius-Constantine,
or again more easily the
Basilica Nova.
Now let me show you where it
is, and by so doing it takes us
back to a Google Earth image
that we've looked at time and
again in the course of this
semester,
and I suppose in the last
lecture it's very appropriate to
go back to this particular
aerial view,
to remind ourselves of
everything we've covered in the
center of Rome.
Just reminding you,
of course, the Circus Maximus
up here,
the Palatine Hill,
originally, with the huts of
Romulus and later with the
Palace of Domitian.
The Capitoline Hill over here,
as redesigned by Michelangelo.
The Wedding Cake of Victor
Emmanuel down here.
The Via dei Fori Imperiali,
the Imperial Fora,
with the Forum of Trajan.
The area that was built up by
Diocletian,
or one of the areas,
was the area over here,
which is where we see the
Curia, which was restored by
Diocletian,
and also the Five Column
Monument, are located on this
side,
closest to the Capitoline Hill.
But Maxentius was particularly
interested in the area,
the uppermost area,
closer to the Colosseum.
If you look right under the
Colosseum,
you can see the remains of the
Temple of Venus and Roma,
which we looked at earlier in
the semester --
a Temple of Venus and Roma that
was the Greek import that
Hadrian built and may have
designed himself in Rome.
And it was that--and I
mentioned this at the time,
but you may have forgotten by
now--that at the time that the
building burned down in a fire;
remember that fire of 283 that
destroyed the Curia also
destroyed part of the Temple of
Venus and Roma,
and it was rebuilt by
Maxentius, by Maxentius,
by the Tetrarch Maxentius.
He rebuilt the Temple of Venus
and Roma, and you'll recall the
niche that is well preserved
with his rebuilding.
So it's not surprising to see
him choosing the location right
next door,
right underneath the Temple of
Venus and Roma for his Basilica
Nova in Rome,
when it begins to be built.
And it still is preserved on
that site today.
I show you a panorama that
includes the Basilica Nova,
and you see it right here,
and you can see how very large
a building it is.
And there are only essentially
three barrel vaults,
a small part of the building,
still preserved.
But it gives you a sense of its
scale, when you compare it to
some of the other structures
here.
But you can see many that we've
studied.
You can see the Temple of
Antoninus and Faustina.
You can see the Arch of
Septimius Severus.
You can see the Curia over here.
You can see the Tabularium,
and the Michelangelo palazzo
that was built into that.
You can see the Victor Emmanuel
Monument over there.
And you can see on this side
the Arch of Titus,
the remains of the Temple of
Venus and Roma,
and so on.
So a very large building in the
midst of an area that Maxentius
was particularly interested in
restoring.
Here's a view of the Basilica
Nova as it looks today.
It's taken from the side,
the other side,
with one's back to the Palatine
Hill.
And we can see here that it is
a building made out of
brick--out of concrete,
excuse me, faced with brick.
We can see that the artists are
better than ever at
dematerializing--the architects
and designers--better than ever
at dematerializing the wall.
They have used very large,
round-headed windows here,
on two stories.
There's more window than
there's wall.
That's how good they've become
at manipulating the brick-faced
concrete medium--you see it in
this wall over here as well.
And you see these three giant
barrel vaults,
with soaring vaults -- a very
impressive work of architecture.
Let me show you a restored view
of what the Basilica Nova would
have looked like in its heyday,
and then let me say a little
bit more about what happens when
Constantine takes over
construction of this particular
building.
This restored view is very,
very interesting because it
shows us that although this
building was used,
without question,
as a basilica--that was its
purpose,
a basilica--we see here that it
is unlike any basilica that we
have seen in the course of this
semester.
And I wonder as you look at
this whether you can tell me if
it's not--it's not built like a
customary basilica;
it doesn't look like the
Basilica Ulpia in Rome.
It doesn't look like the
basilica at Trier.
But it does look like what
other kind of building,
that we've seen time and again
in the course of this semester?
Look at the vaulting,
look at the barrel vaults on
either side.
Look at the shape of the
windows in the upper tier.
exterior of the building that is
created by the choice of
vaulting.
What does this look like?
If not a basilica?
Someone said a market.
Yes which--yes,
who said bath structure?
That's the answer.
Which part of a typical Roman
imperial bath does this look
like?
The frigidarium;
the frigidarium,
the great large rectangular
space, with a triple groin
vaulted roof,
with windows that are usually
divided into three parts,
on the uppermost part,
and then buttressed by great
barrel vaulted chambers.
This is a basilica that is
built in the form of a
frigidarium.
That's an awfully creative
thing to do.
It shows us once again this
interest in the
interchangeability of form;
that you can take a plan that
was used for one kind of
building and use it for another,
as they have done so
effectively here,
using a frigidarium plan
for a basilica,
and capitalizing on that,
to make it work in this
environment as well.
So some very creative minds I
think at work in the time of
Maxentius and in the time of
Constantine.
When the building was first
designed for Maxentius,
the idea was to have the
entranceway on the eastern part
of the building--
the eastern part of the
building, the part of the
building that faces the
Colosseum--
and to enter into it that way,
and to have the main apse be
over here,
on the western end of the
structure,
to give it a longitudinal
focus, and the kind of focus one
would have seen in a typical
frigidarium,
as well as in a typical
basilica.
Constantine comes in,
takes it over,
and decides he wants to change
the orientation.
He wants the entranceway not to
be closest to the Colosseum,
but rather to the Roman Forum,
and to the Sacred Way,
and to the Velia,
which is the part on which this
was built,
to the Arch of Titus.
And he instructs his architects
to change the orientation from
an east-west orientation to a
north-south orientation,
and to place the entranceway on
the Forum side,
on the south.
He also instructs them to put
four columns here,
and these columns are made out
of porphyry,
that purplish stone that's
quarried in Egypt and that was
used so extensively for
Tetrarchic art,
Tetrachic portraiture;
we see that here.
Then he's very tempted to
change the orientation of the
niche;
instead of to put his portrait,
as Maxentius--Maxentius
intended to put his portrait in
this--his own portrait,
that is, of Maxentius--in this
apse.
Constantine was probably
tempted to put his own portrait
in this apse over here,
on the northern side,
so that it would be the first
thing that you saw when you came
in.
But he resisted that temptation
and decided to leave--or to
place a seated portrait of
himself in this niche,
leave it where Maxentius
intended it.
So you would have to enter the
building and take an abrupt left
to see that statue.
But we think--we're not
absolutely sure--we think he may
also have put another statue of
himself, in this case a standing
statue, in this niche.
But as we'll see,
there are lots of niches in the
wall of the northern end,
and we think that there were
statues of all of his
lieutenants;
the lieutenants that had helped
him win his great battle at the
Milvian Bridge,
that were located in this
niche.
And so he may have been shown
there, surrounded by his most
worthy and his most loyal
lieutenants.
And then another statue of him
seated in the niche over here.
So we see him--again the most
important thing is he shifts the
orientation.
Another restored view,
which perhaps--in color--which
perhaps gives you a better sense
of the majesty of this
particular building,
in its time.
The entrance,
the Constantinian entranceway,
through the porphyry columns,
through the doorways,
into the main body of the
structure --
the same kind of marble
pavements with maroon and green
and white,
that we've seen in so many
other buildings,
used here, marble revetment on
the wall.
You can get a sense of the
groin vaults and the way in
which they were probably also
decorated, either with painting
and stucco, or maybe even
mosaic.
The great coffered ceilings of
the barrel vaults.
And look at the way in which
they've created a lateral
entrance,
arched entranceways,
in each of these piers,
to create a greater flow of
space, just as you would see in
a typical frigidarium.
And then again this opening up,
this very impressive opening up
of the walls,
with these exceedingly large
round-headed windows that allow
again light to stream into the
structure.
A real tour de force of Roman
architecture;
in my opinion,
one of the greatest buildings
ever built by Roman architects.
Believe it or not,
we have the portrait of
Constantine still preserved,
and I can show it to you,
or least bits and pieces of it
--
a fairly significant number of
bits and pieces,
including the head,
which I show you here,
which is now on view in the
courtyard of the Conservatori
Palace,
one of the palaces on the
Capitoline Hill that belongs to
the Capitoline Museums.
We see Constantine here,
and you can see how similar he
is to that transformed portrait
that showed him as a
neo-Augustus with a neo-Trajanic
hairstyle: beardless,
very clean shaven,
very large eyes,
but very much in the mode of
the earlier emperors,
Augustus and Trajan,
rather than in the mode of the
Tetrarchs.
And yet a very abstract,
geometric image,
very much in keeping with
Tetrarchic and Constantinian
art, in that regard,
and truly colossal in scale.
We have a lot of the body parts
that are also preserved in that
same courtyard,
from this same statue,
including the shin of the leg,
from the knee down,
the knee itself,
and the way in which the knee
is depicted tells us that the
knee was bent,
and that consequently this did
indeed come from a seated statue
of Constantine,
that statue that would have
been in that left-hand niche.
We also see the famous hand
from the statue,
as well as part of an arm.
And the arm is very impressive,
because if you look at it
carefully you will see that the
musculature is very clearly
delineated,
and you can even see the veins
of the arm showing through the
skin,
which shows you how adept
artists still were during this
time period.
These are right out in the
courtyard of the Conservatori
Palace.
Everybody--there's no tourist,
with a camera,
who goes by here without taking
a photograph in front of it;
including yours truly.
I've done that.
I'm absolutely incapable--it's
hard to say it--
I'm totally incapable of going
into this piazza and not taking
a picture,
either of whomever I'm with,
or them of me,
and I have tons of these from
years and years of posing in
front of this.
It's a pretty good
Mediterranean tan,
I must say, on this side.
But posing with these hands and
feet and so on.
This is my son,
Alex, posing on the foot,
as you can see here.
So one can't--and you can only
imagine.
I imitate the exact gesture up
there, in this image.
But you can only imagine the
kinds of photographs that are
taken in front of that hand,
as tourists have to do.
You can find these actually if
you go on Google Image,
and you can find them quite
readily out there.
So if you do go--this is one of
those other places that I hope
if any of you travel there and
inspiration so moves you,
to take a picture of yourself
and send it to me;
I'd love to see it.
At any rate,
if you put all of those pieces
together--and there are actually
two feet preserved,
two feet; the shin;
the knee;
part of the chest,
which we also have;
that arm that I showed you,
the hand, the infamous hand;
and the head of Constantine.
This is what you get:
a seated statue,
thirty feet tall--you've got a
big building,
you need a big statue--thirty
feet tall,
that sat in the main niche,
that niche to the left as you
entered into the Basilica of
Maxentius-Constantine from the
Roman Forum.
Here's another picture of me,
although you can barely see me.
This was taken--it's amazing
that I was able to take this
picture at one point,
with no one else in it,
because the Forum is usually so
crowded.
But here I'm standing with my
back to us, looking at the
Basilica Nova.
And you can see how vast the
great barrel vaults of the
Basilica Nova are.
There are scholars who argue
that Roman architecture declined
in late antiquity;
and not only architecture but
painting and sculpture as well.
And one could make an argument,
I believe, that Roman painting
and sculpture did decline.
I'm not saying I necessarily
agree that they did,
because art can sometimes
change for reasons that have to
do with trying to articulate a
different message than you've
tried to articulate before,
and a new style may be more
appropriate for that than the
style that you've been using up
to that point.
So I think it's a very complex
matter when you think about
whether art declines or not.
But I will go so far as to say,
without going into it in great
detail,
although I'll say a little bit
more about it momentarily,
when we look at the Arch of
Constantine.
But without saying whether I
believe that Roman sculpture or
painting declines,
I want to say categorically
that I do not believe that Roman
architecture declines.
And I think a building like
this is a case in point.
This, in my opinion,
is again one of the greatest
buildings.
If you compare this to the
Colosseum,
if you compare this even to the
sacred Pantheon,
if you compare this to some of
the bath buildings that we've
talked about,
as impressive as they are,
I think this takes its place,
the Basilica Nova takes its
place among the most impressive
works of architecture that were
left to us by the Romans.
And I think you can see what I
mean, just by looking at this
image.
Because to still be able to
create these kinds of soaring
vaults out of concrete,
to face them with brick,
to create windows that are
large enough to essentially
dematerialize the wall--
and the building still stands,
and still stands today--
the soaring vaults,
those soaring rib vaults,
or groin vaults,
that we see in the center of
this space,
to do that at this kind of
scale is an incredible
architectural feat.
I don't think there's any way
that one can say that
architecture declines during
this period, when one looks at a
building like this.
And also keep in mind how
creative they've been,
that at this point in time
they've decided to create a
basilica in the form of a
frigidarium,
from a typical imperial bath.
That's a very creative thing to
do,
and I think it couldn't have
happened were it not that
architects--
that creative juices were not
continuing to flow for
architects and artisans working
on major projects like these in
the time of Constantine the
Great.
I want to turn from the
Basilica Nova to the Arch of
Constantine, which is the last
ancient monument that I'm going
to show you this semester.
The Arch of Constantine was
constructed by Constantine to
celebrate his victory over
Maxentius at the Battle of the
Milvian Bridge.
We think it was begun in 312
A.D.
and completed in 315 A.D.
It is also possible,
some scholars have suggested
that it's conceivable,
that Maxentius may have begun
this too,
in the same way that he began
the Basilica Nova,
and that Constantine took it
over when he was victorious over
Maxentius at the Battle of the
Milvian Bridge.
We don't know which is the
case, whether it was begun by
Maxentius and finished by
Constantine, or whether
Constantine began it himself.
I'm more likely to favor the
latter, that Constantine began
it himself.
But we do not know,
and it's something that you
should be aware of,
that particular controversy.
But it certainly dates to this
time period, to roughly between
312 and 315 A.D.
One of the reasons that we
believe--
I mean, one of the reasons,
the incontrovertible reason
that we know that the building
was completed by Constantine is
the inscription tells us it's a
Constantinian building,
but also there are friezes here
that depict the Battle of the
Milvian Bridge,
and other battles from that
war, and show us,
of course, Constantine
victorious in those scenes.
It is a triple-bayed arch,
very similar in that regard to
the Arch of Septimius Severus in
the Roman Forum,
and I don't think there's any
question that the general format
of it is based on the Arch of
Septimius Severus,
in the Roman Forum.
It too, like the Arch of
Septimius Severus,
is covered with sculpture,
a veritable billboard
advertising the achievements of
Constantine in this important
battle, and overall.
But we see that of course
instead of the panels,
the excerpts as I described
them, from the Columns of Trajan
or Marcus Aurelius that we see
on the Arch of Septimius
Severus,
we see a very different kind of
sculptural decoration here.
It does cover the entire arch,
and it's interesting primarily
because some of it is
Constantinian.
The parts that are
Constantinian,
that were carved during the
fourth century,
are the spandrels with the
victories;
the spandrels with the river
gods, very much like the Arch of
Trajan at Benevento;
the frieze that encircles all
sides of the monument,
you can see that frieze here;
the pedestals of the columns
were also carved in the
Constantinian period;
and there are two roundels,
two round frames,
on either short side of the
Constantinian monument that were
also done during the
Constantinian period.
But what's particularly
interesting is the fact that all
the rest of the sculpture was
cobbled together from earlier
monuments.
And it won't surprise you to
hear that they were the
monuments of the emperor Trajan,
the emperor Hadrian,
and the emperor Marcus Aurelius
--
all the men whom Constantine
considered the great emperors of
the second century A.D.,
the emperors of the second
century A.D.
with whom he most wanted to
connect himself.
He inserts sculpture from their
monuments into this monument.
We don't know whether these
were monuments that had fallen
into disrepair and were lying in
shambles around the city,
or whether he actually
deliberately took apart earlier
monuments to extract from them
the fragments that he wanted.
Also very interesting is the
fact that in all of these
scenes,
the scenes that are used from
earlier monuments,
he replaces the heads of
Trajan, Hadrian and Marcus
Aurelius with his own portrait.
So he in a sense becomes them
in this arch.
Let me show you quickly a
diagram, which will give you
perhaps a better sense of all of
this.
The Trajanic,
the material from the Trajanic
period includes statues of
Dacians that come from the Forum
of Trajan in Rome,
as well as from two
panels--four panels in fact;
two that are located on the
central bay, on either side,
and two that are located on the
sides on the attic,
in both cases.
Hadrian, the roundels,
eight of them on the two long
sides of the arch,
belong to some lost hunting
monument of Hadrian.
The panels, the vertical panels
that you see in the attic,
come from an arch,
a lost Arch of Marcus Aurelius.
And, as I've already described,
the bases, the spandrels,
and the frieze all belong to
the Constantinian period.
I want to show you those very,
very quickly.
A panel on the left-hand side
from the Forum of Trajan,
representing Trajan returning
to Rome after his victory over
the Dacians.
We think this was a pedestal,
or a base, a podium,
for the Temple of Divine Trajan
that was at the end of the forum
and built by Hadrian.
We see a couple of the Dacians
over here that come from the
Forum of Trajan,
the second story,
in the main part of the forum.
And then here these vertical
panels that we believe come from
a lost Arch of Marcus Aurelius.
Here we see part of the
Constantinian frieze,
with Constantine seated,
now headless,
in the center.
Here we see the roundels from a
lost hunting monument,
we believe, of Hadrian.
You can see a dead lion,
for example,
lying here.
Hadrian has returned from the
hunt, but the head of Hadrian
re-carved as a head of
Constantine.
Another scene over here:
a sacrifice to Hercules,
who is floating in the
uppermost part above.
But again the main thing for us
is just that this comes from--
a Hadrianic monument is reused
here so that Constantine can
associate himself with these
great emperors of the fourth
century .
Another detail showing you the
Dacians,
from the Forum of Trajan,
as well as these panels from
this lost Arch of Marcus
Aurelius,
probably originally dating to
the 170s to 180 A.D.
What you see here are the
spandrels, with victories,
and a victory in the base;
victories triumphant over a
barbarian, who kneels at her
feet.
And if you look at these
scenes, if you look at these
very carefully and you compare
them to the little bit of Roman
sculpture that we've looked at
in the course of this semester--
think of the Ara Pacis,
for example--
when you think back to that and
you look at these figures,
one could agree with the
contention that this is not as
good as it once was.
If you look at this figure of
the doughy season--
the boy who's representing a
season down here,
or this figure of the victory,
who is not depicted with the
same finesse that we see the
victory writing on the shield on
the Column of Trajan,
I think a case can be made that
this is not as well rendered as
it was once upon a time.
You can see that in the river
god;
and you can definitely see it
in this scene here.
This is a scene from the
Constantinian frieze,
depicting the siege of the city
of Verona,
very similar to that siege
scene we saw in the Column of
Trajan with the battering ram.
And I think you can see,
as you look at these figures,
they are much more awkward in
their motions.
Look at these three over here,
with the shields and the
spears.
They are exactly the same as if
they were stamped out of a
cookie cutter.
You don't see the artist taking
the time to create distinction
between them,
as you would see on the south
frieze, for example,
of the Ara Pacis.
Again there may be--there's a
different--
they had different thoughts
behind this of what they're
trying to achieve,
and it may be that this
different style works better for
what they've been trying to
achieve.
We've talked about this move
toward abstraction and toward
geometry and so on.
So it's not that I'm talking
about this in a denigrating way.
I'm saying that it could be
chosen for a different reason
to--it helps them present their
case in a better way.
But I don't--I think it's
undeniable that it isn't as fine
in quality as what we saw
before.
And we see here this scene of
Constantine on the Rostra in the
Roman Forum addressing the
people.
He's got the Five Column
Monument behind him.
But look at these statues on
either side; seated statues.
We can identify them by their
portraits of Hadrian and of
Marcus Aurelius,
which I think demonstrates
without any question--
the head of Constantine is
gone, but he would have been
represented with his
neo-Trajanic hairstyle,
in the center,
flanked by Marcus Aurelius and
by Hadrian.
I think that suggests without
question again that he is
deliberately--
that he has taken these bits
and pieces of sculpture from
other monuments in order to
underscore his relationship to
these great leaders of the pagan
past.
And I want to quote from
Bernard Berenson,
the great art historian,
in a book that he wrote called
The Arch of Constantine,
or the Decline of Form,
in 1954.
And I quote him as we look at
another detail from the
Constantinian frieze:
"These stunted bodies are
swathed in heavy blankets,
or covered with scanty shifts,
both with the folds of the
drapery as unfunctional,
as helplessly chiseled,
as ever European art sank to in
its darkest ages."
So that is a very damning point
of view vis--vis this
sculpture.
But again I think a case can be
made.
But I'd like to say here today
that I don't think the same--I
want to underscore--that I don't
think the same case can be made
for architecture.
When you look at the buildings
that we looked at today,
the Basilica at the Palace of
Constantius Chlorus,
finished by Constantine,
I think you will agree with me
that this is a great building,
and a great building again
rooted in the past,
looking to the future.
When you look at something like
the Tor de'Schiavi,
which we looked at last time,
a tomb that is based on the
Pantheon in Rome,
but has the innovation of the
porthole windows that we talked
about --
architects still innovating,
still looking to the past but
still innovating.
The great Baths of Diocletian,
on the left,
and of Constantine,
that we looked at today.
Huge baths in the imperial
tradition.
Not very different from the
Baths of Trajan or the Baths of
Caracalla;
still as great.
They could still build at this
scale, and they continued to
innovate, exploring new forms
for the caldarium in each
of these cases.
The Minerva Medica that we
talked about today.
Yes, in the tradition of round
buildings,
in traditions of the
explorations of Hadrian at his
villa,
or Rabirius on the Palatine
Hill, but of a grand scale and
with new innovations:
the placement of those windows,
those round-headed windows,
at the base of the dome rather
than the oculus,
the use of a decagonal plan.
Innovative, new,
things that haven't happened
before.
So they are looking to the past.
They are building as well as
they usually build,
and they are continuing to add
new things.
When we look at--in fact,
I'm reminded,
as I think about this,
of the two roundels that were
put up--
that were added to the
Arch--that were put up in the--
that were made in the
Constantinian period for the
Arch of Constantine.
And I show them to you here.
Luna in her chariot;
the moon descending,
a cupid by her side,
and the personification of the
ocean, Oceanus down below.
Luna descending.
And on the other side Apollo,
the sun god,
ascending, from the ocean,
his chariot is going up toward
the sky.
The cupid leads the way with a
torch.
Just as the moon descends and
the sun rises,
civilizations end,
eras end, and other
civilizations come to take their
place.
And what happened at the very
end of ancient Rome is that
Constantine founds a new
capital.
He founds the city of
Constantinople as the capital of
the Roman Empire.
He does that in 324 A.D.,
and he dedicates it as the--
he dedicates this new city of
Constantinople to the god of the
Christians on the 11th of May in
330 A.D.; 330 A.D.
So Constantinople becomes the
new capital, replaces Rome as
the capital of the Roman Empire.
This may not have sounded so
amazing at the start,
because we've already seen the
Tetrarchs creating all kinds of
new capitals;
the creation of a new capital
wasn't that bizarre at this
particular point in time.
But he went on to decorate it
with all kinds of buildings that
look very much like those in
Rome,
and in retrospect we know that
that move of the capital from
Rome to Constantinople signaled
the death of Rome,
at that particular point in
time, not to be resuscitated
again until essentially the
Renaissance.
If we look at some of the
buildings that survive though
from Constantinople,
we will see that they are based
so very closely on those of
Rome: the Hippodrome;
the sculpture at the base of
the obelisk;
the aqueducts of Constantinople;
and of course especially the
famous mosque of Hagia Sophia,
which you see on the left,
which would have been
inconceivable without the
architectural innovations of the
Pantheon.
So although we see that the
capital shifts from Rome to
Constantinople,
that Rome's history at this
point lies in the future,
when it's going to be revived
in the Renaissance;
it's going to be looked at
again in the Baroque period and
into the time of Mussolini and
even today, when Roman
architecture remains so
influential.
But although again the argument
can be made that sculpture and
painting decline,
I think that architecture did
not.
And the lessons that the Roman
architects provided have lasted
the test of time,
that they were passed on,
these architectural wonders
were passed on to the Middle
Ages in the West,
to Byzantium in the eastern
part of the Empire;
that they continued to be
operative in the Renaissance,
in the Baroque period,
in the time of Mussolini,
in the time of Richard Meier,
indeed today.
And I believe that they will
continue to be significant for
anyone designing buildings.
They will provide an
inspiration for at least the
next 2672 years.
Thank you very,
very much this semester for
joining me on what has been a
special adventure this semester,
and I again want to thank you
for that.
And that's it.
Thank you.
>